HEAD COACH UNDER THE ARMSTRONG
NOW SAAD, ANOTHER PASS
GREAT FEED, TO THOMAS, FIRESIF ,
McEACHRON BATTLING BACK.
WHAT A ROAD TRIP FOR THE BLUESUG
VERY, VERYN 2018.
TH CENTER ONE. SAVE BY HUSSO ANA
LATETE THOMAS.
AND NOW THE LOST
IT, COYOTES CENTER IT UNDER SHOT
HIGH FOR 47 SAVES INER FOR MACC.
LOST THE PUCK AND THE BLUES COME
>> John: ALL TERRIFIC
PLAYMAKERS,
WEEKS AGO WAS BEING LOOKED TO
LOOKED HIS LEG.
GALCHENYUK HAS NOT GONE BUCHNEV.
HERE IS LETTY AT THE LINE FOR TE
ENTRY INTO THE ZONE BY LEDDY. P.
>> John: HERE'S TARASENKO NOW
FOR SCHENN..
IT'S NOT -- YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
SHAYNE GOSTISBEHERE BACK TO GET
IT, FORMER NCACA>> Darren: HECKY
THE FACE-OFF WAS AT CENTER ICE.
>> John: THAT!
BACK, KEPT ALIVEE
LINEUP AND
NOW BROKEN UP BY THE BLUES
WHAT A PASS BY ROBERT THOMAS
RIGHT  LOCKER ROOM --
>> Darren: ALL I KNOW IS THIS
IS A BIG WEEK
PIPE. IN
SCHMALTZ, IN THERE WITHEND OF TN
PARAYKO GETS A HOLD OF IT ANAN G